- Narrator: Foxes cower at his name.
Polar bears follow his every order.
The name Mr. Big strikes
fear into the heart
of many a predator in Zootopia,
as well it should.
Mr. Big, after all, is an arctic shrew
and shrews are fearsome predators.
Turns out, some of the most
formidable hunters in nature
come in surprising packages.
Quick, think of a fearsome predator.
What comes to mind?
Crocodiles, cobras, tigers?
You might not think to flee at the sight
of this Northern Short-tailed Shrew,
and that would be a mistake.
These tiny guys can take down prey over
twice their size with a single bite.
Their secret?
Venomous Spit.
These shrews are one of
the only mammals on Earth
with a toxic bite.
But even they can't contend
with our next hunter.
The mongoose.
They mostly dine on
insects, small reptiles,
birds, and rodents.
But some species also go after
cobras, mambas, and other venomous snakes.
And, sure, it takes guts to
battle a full-hooded cobra
but there's more to this
bravery than meets the eye.
These mongooses are resistant to
neurotoxins in snake venom.
Normally, the toxins bind
to muscle cell receptors,
which block signals from the
brain, causing paralysis,
but some mongooses have
specially-shaped receptors
that fend off the toxins.
Next up, the giant otter.
On average, their about as
long as a human man is tall,
and usually prefer prey
like catfish and piranas,
but on rare occasions,
they've been known to go after
prey at least twice their length,
like anacondas and croc-like caimans.
And they don't even have secret weapons,
like toxic saliva for help;
just their fellow otters.
But believe it or not,
there's another type of weasel who goes
after even bigger quarry.
The wolverine.
Wolverines are about the
size of a border collie,
and they've been known to hunt caribou.
They like to ambush their prey,
and when that doesn't work,
they have the gall to try and steal prey
from larger predators
like wolves and bears.
Last, but certainly not least,
is perhaps the most unsuspecting
predator of them all.
Meet the epomis beetle.
Right after birth,
these hungry larvae are
already on the hunt.
Frogs, toads, and
salamanders are a tasty meal,
but the newborns can't just
chase these large meals down.
Instead, they lure their prey
by tricking it into attacking them.
Then, they swing around,
sink their hooked jaws into
the flesh, and latch on.
Mmm. Lunch time.
Whether you're dealing
with a beetle or a weasel,
the lesson's clear: size isn't everything.
Which of these fearsome
predators surprised you the most?
Let us know in the comments,
and thanks for watching.